alors on va rappeler déjà ce qu'est le
halal alors c'est la nourriture que la
communauté musulmane est autorisé à
consommer selon un rite d'abattage
spécifiques cela permettrait donc aux
enfants musulmans de manger de la viande
à la cantine sans perturbé
l'alimentation bien sûr des autres
enfants qui peuvent aussi manger de la
viande halal alors le halal à la cantine
pour ou contre
alors eric naulleau alors on voit que
nos deux intervenants nous ont rejoints
merci merci merci d'être là mais un
maire non merci alors on va rappeler
julien julien sanchez donc vous êtes
maire rassemblement national de
beaucaire dans le gard et on a vu la
décision que vous avez prise et bien sûr
achten chalghoumi vous le connaissez
c'est le président des imams de france
et imam de drancy
merci merci d'être là alors déjà eric
naulleau vous vous êtes contre oui je
contre le halal en france je vois pas
très bien où est le débat parce que
servir des repas halal c'est contrevenir
à la laïcité dans ce qu'elle a de plus
basique
donc ce n'est pas possible si des
parents veulent que leurs enfants
mangent des repas consacré il faut qui
les inscrivent dans des écoles
confessionnelles que ça soit qu'ils
soient musulmans ou juifs
en revanche il est évident qu'il faut
proposer un autre plat quand il ya un
plat avec du porc moi je n'ai jamais été
dans un restaurant où le type à l'entrée
me dit vous savez ici ses ports ou rien
donc il est normal qu'ils aient deux
plats dont un ne comprennent pas de porc
alors là alors c'est pas seulement le
porte parce que oui ils peuvent pas non
plus manger de boeuf puisqu'ils doivent
être voilà il doit avoir des rituels
voilà comme comme comme si la viande
casher
le train c'est pas très compliqué à
organiser je sais mais le postulat de
départ eric c'est que tout le monde peut
manger de la viande halal alors que tout
le monde ne peut pas manger la viande
dit voilà c'est contraire à la laïcité
voilà d'accord dans les grandes villes
postulant
oui voilà tout à fait ça permettra des
enfants dans des écoles confessionnelles
ils font ce qu'ils veulent
la laïcité on ne peut pas admettre de la
nourriture consacré religieusement dans
des écoles publiques la laïcité
française est assez simple à comprendre
de ce point de vue je pense que ça peut
fonctionner sans drame
mais évidemment je regrette beaucoup
voilà les d initiative catastrophique de
mon voisin qui se sert de ce qui se sert
de ce problème pour essayer de semer la
zizanie quoi alors justement voilà
justement julien sanchez
vous avez pris deux mesures c'est que
tous les mercredis voilà vous fait il
doit avoir de la cantine à la cantine un
plat avec du porc donc du porc à la
cantine tous les mercredis c'est votre
mesure
non ce qui a été fait très simplement
c'est que depuis mon prédécesseur donc
depuis l'ancien maire de beaucaire
unique était qu'elles feront au divers
droite uniquement les jours ou du porc
étaient servis à la cantine des repas de
substitution étaient proposés à cette
époque et non c'est pas top parce que on
prend en compte un interdit religieux
dans l'école de la république et donc on
prend en compte cet interdit religieux
et on propose autre chose pourquoi le
port n'est pas un événement parfaitement
raisonnable mais il faut dès la
prochaine étape ce sera de demander du
halal à la cantine pas du tout bien sûr
qu'ils vont tiers disent certains
parents le demandent et des faux pas
leur accorder
eh bien oui il faut pas accorder moins
de substitution mais si je suis certain
idéal alors on va les enfants musulmans
contre on va leur dire non on n'a rien
pour toi tu mangeras que une banane au
dessert on avait écouté il ya des
enfants ont toujours eu des plats qu'il
n'aimait pas les choux de bruxelles où
il y en à la cantine ils les laissent
ils n'en mange pas et bien quand pour
des raisons personnelles et pour des
choix de leurs parents et uniquement
cela parce que j'entends dire qu'un
enfant de trois ans il décide tout seul
de ne pas manger parce que les missions
religieuses l'offre à le faire je
l'avais bien l'enfant laisse dans
l'assiette ce plat et c'est pas un
restaurant aux trois étoiles une
candidate hâtif une cantine et quand
même on n'a pas à servir tout le monde
ceux qui vont faire la politique sur le
dos des gosses non mais le bon sentiment
de la gauche ne sait ce que c'est un
dénoncer les mauvais signaux ont fait de
l'émotion juste juste monsieur champions
juste pour vous dire quelque chose vous
pouvez pas dire un enfant lui il a il
aura envie de manger voilà deux du port
il n'a pas décidé toute seule un enfant
aussi lu ici un enfant lors il a envie
aussi de faire n'importe quoi et de d2
d'écrire sur les murs on va pas dire oui
bah s'est il emballé s'écrire souris mur
mais là c'est n'importe quoi ce que vous
dites quand vous dites un nouveau deal à
d'autres plats qu'ils aiment pas ils
n'aiment pas le chou et pourtant il est
là il est maintenant mais c'est celle ci
n'a rien à voir la religieuse qui ont
été le plus jeune à sa rentrée et après
on rencontre les interdits religieux
vous êtes content quand même ambitieux
on est content et alors dites nous
pourquoi
bonjour à tous je viens de dire eric
dans un espace laïque non c'est pas
possible
maintenant il faut aussi parler
d'intégration c'est aussi simple que
celui de bonnes chances c'est
l'intégrale à l'envers c'est bien sûr la
grève quand il recommandé j'ai touché en
était moins dense avec la moindre des
choses dans mon gsm temps voilà moi je
suis content parce que j'ai repas qu'à
la cantine cela divise les gens qui vont
agir la religion d'un côté ceux qui ne
marchent pas et sharon de l'autre moi je
la région et parra pour diriger et n'a
existé
par ailleurs il faire une hystérie
avance à la pause et la substitution
c'est le sens belgique c'est juste les
directives ministérielles qui disent
l'inversé elles disent que nous n'avons
pas adapté la cantine au choix qu'on
fait ce que nous faisons c'est vraiment
la vie de karim zéribi qui est contre
moi j'écoutais tout le monde laïc mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on écoute mans mon
argumentaire moi je suis contre parce
que je considère que dans une république
laïque
aucune religion quelle qu'elle soit nous
devons imposer ses principes à
l'ensemble de la population
sinon nous ne serions plus une
république laïque ne sont une république
religieuse à connotation religieuse ce
qui n'est pas le cas de notre pays et la
laïcité est une chance
il faut que nous défendions ses
principes
en revanche si je suis contre la
généralisation du halal dans les
cantines ce que ça voudrait dire que se
plie à un précepte religieux et g2 mais
on me dirait le cacher je dirais pareil
demain on me dirait le végétarienne
parce qu'elle est bouddhiste je dirais
pareil je dirais la même chose
je suis favorable au repas de
substitution et je les comprends pas
pourquoi ce débat sert aujourd'hui les
fonds de commerce politique nauséabond
dans la mesure où quand j'étais gamin je
venais dans les années 60 ce que on nous
donnait un repas de substitution
il n'y avait pas de débat à ce sujet au
menu une omelette quand il y avait une
tranche de jambon
on m'a volé un oeuf au plat quand il y
avait deux qu'une autre h2 et moi vous
avez faire tous les repas de la semaine
en réalité syrie
c'est important oui je le veux dire par
là c'est que il ne doit pas y avoir de
généralisation parce que nous sommes un
pays laïque et nous ne devons pas céder
aux règles religieuses pour l'ensemble
de la population
la liberté de conscience ça compte chez
nous de croire ou de ne pas croire
et donc il faut respecter les religieux
comme les non religieux deuxièmement ils
font repas de substitution
on peut pas laisser un gamin ne pas
manger au nom de sa religion c'est pas
la république non plus et troisièmement
on est en train de
débattre de sujets permettez moi de vous
le dire est ce qu'il ya une
revendication de la communauté musulmane
qui demande le halal n'ont jamais de la
main j'avais donc ça veut dire que à
chaque fois sur ses débats hystérique
on déballe de sujets qui concernent côté
musulmane comme si elle avait revendiqué
quelque chose qu'elle n'a en réalité
jamais revendiqué détruit son père ne se
sont jamais organisée pour dire et
manifester pour de le halal dans les
cantines alors s'il vous plaît ne
parlait pas alors alors alors non mais
attendez parce que là à mine de rien on
à hassen chalghoumi qui est avec nous
merci d'être là vous est ce que vous
êtes pour ou est-ce que vous êtes qu est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec karim
zéribi qui dit que la communauté
musulmane nahd mais tu m'as tu n'as
jamais rien demandé tout à fait je
partage cette façon et vous savez il ya
quelques parents ils demandent ça c'est
clair et à quelques parents une demande
d'essai de demander à l'établissement
scolaire parce qu'il ya une possibilité
de trouver en plats halal et là ça
dépend la possibilité j'étais pour ces
c'est possible ça dépend de personne qui
en pose mais malheureusement je suis
tout à fait contraire aux contres donc
posé les choses donc posé là des enfants
et la religion hélas pas à son rôle de
ces d'imposer s'est pressée dans les
écoles on sent là ils tiraient tous
d'accord que la major dans le cadre
choisi ras al hajji et d'imposer le port
pour tous les élèves vocation ça c'est
la provocation dans ce cas là nous les
musulmans ont fait le vendredi couscous
et le mardi je sais pas quoi
si vous faites ce que vous voulez à
celui ma mère mais pas dans l'école de
la république est une priorité pour les
élèves de choisir on peut trouver des
plats c'est mes enfants et donner un
teint enfants dans une école tête du
communautarisme maison jamais de
charisme là vous criez le capitalisme
vous savez le seul maire pardonnez moi
oui il exclure ça veut dire directement
les maghrébins et les musulmanes non le
fpi voulait introduire dans les cantines
à mettre les religieux ne mange pas les
chalands territoire équilibré qui m'a
posée à chacun et on n'est pas dans un t
shirt toile les régions une défaite
rhétorique de parler de repas de
substitution
depuis quand il y aurait un plat unique
des coûts de cantines de france brille
et bah oui mais de nous un passé quand
in science elle fut un million et demi
d'euros d'une cantine c'est un
restaurant scolaire ça ne paraît pas
extravagante atypique propose
oui qu'on propose deux plats vous
essayez vous essayez de créer de faux
problèmes ont assez de véritables non
pas du tout c'est votre problème parce
que vous essayer d'exploiter à fond
traire ans de sortir un peu des gants
querelles politiques à qui croît de
petites querelles politiques
oui c'est petit le propre pourquoi même
contre le problème qui lie à nommer fo
il faut le dire le problème qu'il y ait
de problème très très différent d'abord
moi ce que je déteste ces chosifié une
communauté tous les musulmans leurs
prêts papa un accord qui est de la même
façon qu'ils mangent de la même façon
qu'ils vident la même façon arrêtons de
chosifie que ça soit les musulmans les
juifs les chrétiens
ça suffit il y a un problème on le sait
très bien par un certain nombre de
territoires de la république où
effectivement aux troupes plus de
charcuterie faut le dire ça aussi
raconté faut arrêter
on n'est pas pour la charcuterie le gars
on est en santé andré l'art et la
question aller simple est ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre les quand tu vois la
limite pourquoi mais on n'est pas qu'est
ce que ça veut dire cantines hallal
moi je suis pour que chacun puisse avoir
la liberté de manger ce qu'il veut alors
oui mais mine de rien il faut que les
cantines il faut que les cantines minera
s'organise pouvez pas dire lorsqu'on
veut ça coûte de là alors alors il faut
les moyens il faut les moyens
c'est donc ici que je voudrais écouter
les vieux qui sont grands jusqu'à la
clio qui sombre in situ et christine
kelly vous êtes faits qui je veux
absolument qu'on respecte la laïcité
c'est clair en revanche pourquoi je dis
que je suis peau simplement pour la
tolérance un minimum de tolérance dans
la société un peu de tolérance c'est
tout après je respecte la laïcité
je suis entièrement d'accord avec
seulement christine oui on apprend la
tolérance mais moi je suis en même temps
c'est pas penser contre oui entre la
laïcité la tolérance je préfère un
épagneul adhérents je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec avec eric avec karim je
pense que c'est la laïcité rien que la
laïcité que la laïcité est évidemment
des repas de substitution
donc là le port imposé c'est vraiment
une provocation idée logique totalement
malsaine mais mais en revanche n'ont en
aucun cas la religion doit être plus
forte que l'état doit être plus forte
que le droit et elle n'a pas rentré
elle n'apparaît qu'en faisait alors la
prochaine l'approché stylistique moi lol
c'est pas un dîner c'est vrai vous a
réussi et ça nous faisait ici s'est
imposé à tous je suis contre mais c'est
super et on vous voudriez que les
cantines ça devienne un club med donc
faut-il alors là
non mais je vais vous dire pourquoi moi
je suis pour la tolérer oui mais non
mais non rien on a failli aller chez
rythme si juste j'aimerais j'aimerais
avoir l'avis d'eric revel et après
dernier sujet quand même je voulais
poser la question monsieur le maire il
ya un truc il faut jamais oublier c'est
que pour beaucoup d'enfants
j'ai pas un chiffre en tête le repas à
la cantine c'est parfois le seul repas
de la journée
donc moi je ne veux pas d'une république
laïque à géométrie variable donc moi je
suis content mais en revanche si
pardonnez moi mais par positionnement
politique vous oubliez ce petit détail
qui est très important dans un pays qui
est en proie et de connaissances vous
des mois mais attendez à faire est-ce
que vous rebute ces beaux messieurs mais
la raison donc juste vous avez dit qu'il
est hyper sympa qu'on trouve là son
contenant dans son contre votre mesure
voilà sur la mesure que vous avez pris
ce que la majorité des français et pour
donc sur les repas pour que la fin
justement à gâteau proof pour demain
mais justement sur ce soit la sauce sur
ce sujet là il n'y a aucune interdiction
et obligations à l'échelle nationale
c'est à dire que chaque ville chaque
région peut choisir ou non de
l'appliquer et de l'adapter et il ya le
cas à strasbourg par exemple depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années la cantine des
écoles proposent un menu avec ou sans
porc à un prix au 1er prix jean propose
un menu halal au choix alain prix plus
élevés et un menu végétarien a pris
également adapté surtout pas échappé que
le concordat
mais bien sûr mais c'est que c'est c'est
quelque chose de possible que mes moyens
exactement mais on n'est pas dans un
espace laïque
c'est bizarre de vouloir compliqué
quelque chose de très simple pour des
raisons bassement politiques et
démagogique
on va prendre on va prendre une
comparaison footballistiques le la
laïcité elle est là le cacher et le
halal sont hors jeu de proposer d un
repas sans porc
ça reste dans la laïcité vous êtes dans
l'absolu membres a fait n'est pas du
tout ce sont des habitudes ce sont des
infidèles unitaire mais ce n'est pas
consacré au sens que ce n'est pas cacher
ou ce n'est pas halal et à la tolérance
je pourrais perdre consignes c'est
justement ça c'est de proposer à ses
enfants de manger ce qu'ils veulent mais
dans beaucoup de villes les maires de
même plus de porc parce que justement
ils veulent éviter le problème et ça
c'est un scandale aussi c'est ça la
réponse de la châtaigne et non plus
chaque derby donc c'est tellement simple
c'est ça ma peau des enfants et comme le
dit eric image qu'une fois par jour et
de leur dire mais vous aimez part ça
vous avez ça ça me semble pas compliquer
sa gamme et l'arrivée donc vous vous
adapter à toutes les revendications
gamin si quelqu'un nous dit qu'il veut
pas de boeuf et les gens voient les
choses à dire autre chose qu'à la
cantine avait pas que j'avais pas vu
sinon 18 100 douilles avaient pas ce
monsieur je touche et olivier j'étais
petit et que je pourrai ce que j'aime et
vous vous méconnaissez les réalités
concrètes qui font que dans la plupart
des communes de france sauf dans les
grandes il n'y a pas de self et donc on
ne peut faire qu'un l'audience et allez
on va on va t elle faire encore une fois
je crois que sur toutes ces questions
sociétales
c'est le bon sens qui doit primer et pas
les fonds de commerce politique de
gauche d'extrême parce que les français
n'ont que faire des fonds de commerce ce
qu'ils veulent c'est du pragmatisme
intelligent donc augmenter ces gens
c'est quoi ma cote chez les enfants
mathis politique c'est quoi ma chère il
crie pas si c'est parce qu'elle en
retard que c'était la yaris est en paix
ses effets des semaines
très de ne rien n'obligeait et
effectivement je suis contre un corps
aux mains je le dis pas su pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent pour être très clair je
suis contre la généralisation du halal
tout le monde sait que je pense qu'ils
feront des repas de substitution se
nourrissaient l'hérault veulent
respecter les religions
ça n'est pas effectivement faire de
notre république laïque une république
religion alors on met pas anti religieux
quand on est laïque
j'aimerais quand même qu'on clara
conclusion voilà vous vouliez dire
quelque chose depuis tout à l'heure ce
que vous pouvez faire une conclusion là
dessus tu renvoies la conclusion de me
suis inquiète et monsieur chalghoumi je
suis contre toute imposition quel que
soit de porc ou de la viande halal ou de
repas halal dans la comptine ça c'est
clair mais en même temps je voulais
savoir quel signe quand vous ne donnez
un lundi par exemple que tout le monde
soit obligé de mondial par personne
n'est obligé la salle une photo a fait
croire qu'on leur a offert dans la
bouche voir un tel nom mais vous
l'obligé qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
dites moi c'est quoi la solution
personnellement et nicole c'est un
exemple
c'est l'exemple c'est le meilleur je
l'aï interposant je suis contre qu'on
oppose deux allèles et je suis contre
aussi qu'on oppose aussi pareil parce
que dieu est grand nous avons été
réellement équilibrée monsieur alors ça
veut dire dieu est grand pour tout le
monde pour tous les peuples c'est ce qu'
au moins appris les croyants fête dieu
est grand pour tous les monothéistes
ceux qui mangent du porc ceux qui
mangent du halal ce qu'ils mangent des
souches est vrai même règlement des
sushis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]